hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode eight video part two
of the big crossover setting up legends
of tomorrow just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet the
reverse flash ring giveaway is also
still going on now all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video because I
already explained most of their
backstory hawkman hawkgirl Vandal Savage
in yesterday's episode I'm gonna start
with top 5 WTF and then I'll just do all
the extra Easter eggs there was a bunch
of extra stuff
most notably Oliver's son but here we go
top 5 WTF starting with flash back to
ancient Egypt we thankfully actually did
get the origin sequence we get to see
the JLA origin story for Hawkman and
Hawkgirl I'll argue that it's a bigger
change for vandal savages character than
it is for Hawkman and Hawkgirl like the
Hawkman and Hawkgirl part of it is
almost exactly from the comics Vandal
Savage is just replacing the hath-set
character in that origin story so the
cool thing there though is is that they
definitely confirm enth metal so those
falling sky rocks that destroy King
Ramses Empire are nth metal meteors that
makes you wonder how much of that is
stuck on the planet like Cisco makes
that little nth metal GPS device for her
at the end maybe they'll end up using it
as like the DC universes vibranium very
rare but very precious so naturally enth
metal is the key to defeating Vandal
Savage
but even still even though they added
enth metal to the special gloves to the
power gloves that they gave to Barry it
still takes a lot of power to defeat
FanDuel savage speed which on a my
number 4 WTF their first try to kill
Vandal Savage completely fails everyone
dies in this horrible explosion and
Oliver says run Barry run some eater in
the episode were asked me you know like
why did Barry see like the second Barry
running next to him well it turns out he
was just time-traveling and you can kind
of tell that they want to speed through
certain parts of the logic in the
episode like Barry emedia is like oh you
know I think I time-traveled he doesn't
think that it's anything else for those
that are asking why they don't do that
more often
they're actually gonna address that on
legends of tomorrow like dirt being
through time we can totally change our
past and nothing bad will happen that's
gonna be addressed on their time-travel
show under my number 3 WTF Vandal Savage
round 2 so I guess the first time it's
implied that everyone's distracted they
don't have everything they need mentally
or physically they're just not able to
win but the second time they learn about
the enth metal twist because all over it
gives Cisco the big call to action talk
- the woman you clearly love I don't
know if we're at the l-bomb yet so the
fight sequence is pretty spectacular in
the way that they kill Vandal Savage is
really cool - like he just turns into a
pile of ash giant question mark cuz it's
like hey we just we saw him in the
legends of tomorrow trailer how does he
come back there's really two things
there so onto my number two WTF
Merlyn gathers vandal savage's ashes in
a special urn
speaks the same words that Savage was
speaking to Hawkman and Hawkgirl about
his hate following them across all time
and says you owe me one buddy
so you just shake your fist in the air
just go Barrow man but the real question
is is what is Merlyn gonna do to those
ashes does he know about another Lazarus
Pit from what the showrunners have said
the Lazarus Pit is the only lazarus pit
so unless it's like the comics and there
are Lazarus pits all over the earth I'm
not really sure how Merlin's gonna bring
him back dollars to doughnuts it's gonna
involve some form of magic but just to
clarify at no point in the comics has
anyone ever been able to dump in urn of
ashes into a lazarus pit to resurrect
someone again it actually has to be a
real body like they have to be somewhat
whole but they're definitely not gonna
explain that to legends of tomorrow
episode 1 now that airs Thursday January
21st I saw some of you guys asking about
the schedule the flash arrow and legends
of tomorrow all come back that third
week in January so it's Tuesday the 19th
then the 20th and the 21st and it'll be
three nights I think legends of tomorrow
has at least like 12 or 13 episodes it
might even be 16 I don't know if it's
been confirmed yet but aside from
Oliver's child it was a great way to in
the episode like Merlin gets to be the
villain that he's supposed to be it's
fun to see Merlin work with the team but
like when he gets up at all over his
face and it's like I will end you if
something happens to Thea that's the
Merlin you want to see but of course on
my number one WTF moment Oliver meets
his son and they have a moment together
so here's the big explainer for this
that the showrunners actually did
explain that is not Connor Hawke his
name is William Clayton the reason why
they chose not to make him Connor Hawke
is because they knew they probably
wouldn't be able to use that child actor
on the show but they still wanted to be
able to do Connor Hawke so legends of
tomorrow we'll get the connor hawke
character it just won't be all of her
son so the next big question like how
often is Oliver gonna visit this child
like how is that gonna work what's going
on with him and Felicity because he lied
to her
second time and that was kind of a big
deal the first time so the showrunners
also confirmed that the live will become
a big deal they're like if there's any
secrets on the show they always come out
so eventually Felicity's gonna find out
they'll be huge fallout but we don't
know how that's gonna go
they didn't say whether or not it's
gonna nuke olicity or anything like that
but I think what's gonna happen with
Oliver's child is is that we won't see
him on screen
Oliver will just mention him a couple
times this season but don't expect any
big storylines with all of her son to be
happening they said that they were
essentially paying that off for good
with this scene here so even if you're
bummed out that all of our son is in
connor hawke just be excited that we'll
get a version of connor hawke on the
show that will actually be called connor
hawke couple other Easter eggs of note
when they talk about st. Roch's
University that that tape where they
learn about the enth metal st. Roch's
Louisiana is the place that hawkman and
hawkgirl are from in the comics they're
also gonna visit that place during
legends of tomorrow Vandal Savage also
drops a bomb
I taught Robin of Locksley to use a bow
he taught me to not feel pain so lots of
fun stuff just expect in the future
whenever they air this is reruns to air
these episodes back-to-back cuz it
really is kind of like a two-hour movie
setting up legends of tomorrow here's my
big question for you guys though like
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment but the real big
question is is next year because they'll
have legends of tomorrow all these other
extra characters do you think that
they'll try to expand the crossover
there's been talks of a Supergirl
crossover she might crossover with the
flash would you want to see an even
bigger crossover do you think they'd be
able to accomplish that or do you think
they'd have to do it in like four
episodes instead of just two the problem
when you have all these characters on
screen is that you can't always do
service to all of them so sometimes it
helps to have fewer things going on in
episodes and that doesn't really work
for big big huge crossovers so yeah it
would be awesome to see like Supergirl
and Constantine show up during the arrow
flash crossover next year somehow I
don't think that the story would be able
to accommodate them so if we do see like
a Supergirl crossover at some point
it'll probably just be with one of the
shows by itself like it'd probably be an
arrow crossover and a flash crossover at
the same time but in related big news if
you guys didn't know there's a new
Batman for Superman trailer posting
tonight depending on when it drops
either this video will have posted first
or that video but either way I'll put a
link in the description so no worries
well you guys wait just in case you have
see even click here for that Batman vs
Superman trailer and you can click here
for part 1 of the cross over the flash
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight